はじめ）よしっ！
は）しー－ーー
は）やりますか
たくみ・まさき）やりますか(小声)
は）いや、しゃくれてねーよ！　ま）ｗｗｗ
た）俺、はじめより座高高い
は）嘘でしょう？
は）あ、でも同じくらい？
はははは(^^)
は）結構重大な
は）場面だよ　ま）いやいやほんと
は）マジで歴史じゃん　ま）重大発表だよ
は）はい！こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
た）たくみふくしゃちょーと
ま）まさき取締役です
は）はい
は）今日は
は）大事な告知です
は）とっても大事な告知だと思います
は）まあこの2人
は）たくみ君とまさき君が、いると思うんですけど
ｗｗｗｗｗ
は）笑ったもんｗ
は）まあ笑ってはいるんですけども
は）あの～まあ
は）たくみが去年
は）こっちに戻ってきてくれて
は）まさきが
は）今年のもうすぐだね？　ま）うん
は）もうすぐ
は）大学院を卒業ということなん
ですけども
は）えー。。
は）今年の春までに
は）2人とも
は）僕の
ｗｗｗｗｗ
は）待って、ほんとにｗ
た）なったよね
は）今年の春までに
は）われわれは
は）一時
は）解散というわけになります！！
は）拍手しよう
は）拍手です、拍手です
は）どっから話していけばいいんだろ？
は）どこだろう？ジャンケンで決めますか？
ま）そんな感じなの？ｗｗ
最初はグー、ジャンケンぽん
は）いやお腹はすいてんだよね
ま）おれから？
は）そうですね
ま）えっと。。この
ま）3月
ま）で一応、大学院を
ま）修了する
ま）という事で
ま）えっと、大学入ってからはホントもう
ま）まる6年位
は）6年だね
ま）長いねｗ　は）やばいねｗ
ま）大学4年と大学院2年、あわせて6年間一緒に
ま）動画出たりとか
ま）してやってきたんですけど
ま）この大学院を卒業する
ま）タイミングで
ま）とりあえず
ま）ひとくぎりという事で
ま）来年度4月からは
ま）長野の方に戻って
ま）向こうでとりあえず一年、先生を
ま）中学校の
ま）音楽の先生を
ま）やります
ま）はい
ふふふふふｗ
ま）今までずっと学生だったし
ま）まあこれ、YouTube
ま）関連の事しか全然やってないので
ま）来年は働いて
ま）まあただ、来年度、1年間働いた
後っていうのがまだ
ま）決まってないので
ま）まあどうなるか、全然まだ分かん
ないですけど
ま）ひと区切りという事で
ま）この3月で
ま）卒業？　は）卒業だね
ま）卒業します
は）お疲れしった
ｗｗｗｗｗ
ま）かるいなｗ　は）軽くはないですけど
は）まあでも、なんだろうな？
は）まさきはホントに
は）YouTubeやってきて 約6年だもんね
は）約6年やってきて
は）まぁ唯一
は）最初から最後まで
は）常に僕の事を見てきた
は）唯一の1人だもんね、、ほんとに
は）その彼がいなくなるっていうのは結構
は）デカいっす、、
は）僕の中でも
は）まあでもこれは
は）彼が決めたことなので
は）え～皆さんはぜひ
は）応援してあげてほしいと思
っております
は）たくみに関してはどっちかっていうと2人のアレだもんね
た）たしかに
は）あの～去年たくみが帰ってきて
は）まぁ、一緒にこう、夏？からかな
は）夏前位から一緒にやってきたんですけども
は）まぁそんな、悪い意味にとらえて欲しくないです
は）悪い意味にとらえて欲しくないです
けども
は）良くも悪くも
は）お互いにちょっとやりたい
事というか
は）なんて言えばいいの？
た）なんて言えばいいんだろうね
た）雇い雇われの関係だと
お互いにすごい
た）やりにくかったんだよね
は）友達だったんだよね、ずっと大学の
は）同い年、仲良く一緒に
は）やってきたんで
は）このままこう
は）一緒に働くと結局 、おいらが
最初に
は）いて、後からたくみが来たわけだから
は）この、変な上下関係なんだけど
は）実際は、、
は）友達だから
は）そこでなんか変なね、すれ違いというか、、
た）今までは俺で仕事をして
た）そこで普通に
た）まっ、生活してて、で、その
た）追加として
た）はじめとの関りがあって
た）それは大学時代も同じで
た）大学の部活とか、大学の他のコミュニティも持ちつつ
た）はじめと一緒にいる時間もあってていう
た）お互いにお互いの
た）軸が、、こう、、
た）ある状態で関わってたからこそ
た）いい感じを、味を出せてたのかな？ってところが
た）この夏以降は
た）完全にはじめがいて
た）で、その下に
た）まっ、これは当然動画出る以上、下にいることに変わりはないけど、
た）私生活に関するところまで
た）やとう側とやとわれる側の関係に
変わってきて
た）で、お互いに
た）やっぱり友達として、やってきたところから
た）やとうやとわれるって関係が入ってくると
た）どうしてもギクシャクしてきちゃってたよね
は）うん、なんかこう、、今までとは違った感じになってきてたなって言うのは…
は）あって
は）まぁそこもお互いに、ちゃんと話し合った結果
は）別々の道に…
は）行くことになりました
た）はじめの必要とする時は、もちろん全部
た）手伝いに行くし
た）人手が必要とか、ここの仕掛けられやってほしいというのがあれば
た）もう騙されてでも行くので
た）そこは変わらないんだけど
は）そうそう、どっちにしろ
は）映像にかかわっていく仕事に、行ってくれるし
は）結局
は）彼をこっちに
は）こっちの世界に呼んだのは、僕なんで
は）まぁ、要約すると
は）春までに
は）解散してしまいます
は）なんて？？
は）ま～あの～、ひとつ皆さんに勘違いしてほしくないのは
は）決してここ3人がギクシャクしたとか
は）なんかケンカしたとか、そういう訳では全くないので
は）それだけは、勘違いしないでいただきたい所でございます
は）まぁ、ここからそれぞれの道という事で
は）どうなるんだろうね。。。　ま）ねっ。。。
は）まだわかんないもんね、先の事は…　た）わかんないね
は）ひょっとしたら1年後にまた
ま）うん、かもしんないし
は）何か戻ったり、どっかでつながったりするかもしれないし
ま）ね、普通に次
ま）UUUMのイベントとか最前列で
ｗｗｗｗｗ
ま）ペンライトとか、ふってるかもしれないｗ
は）まぁ何が…
は）起こるかわかんないし、まあとりあえず来年は
は）まさきと会う事は、あんまりないのかもしんないね...
ま）ねぇ、もう。
は）たくみとはまた別の、東京とかであうかもしれないんですけど
は）という感じで
は）これだけは皆さんに行っておきたいと思います
は）違う思いました
は）っていう感じかな　ま）はい
ま）本当に仲良しだからね
みんな）まぁホントに！たしかに！
ま）普通にプライベートとして、会えればいいなって感じなんで
は）そうだねー...
は）ヤバイ、これで本当にはじめカンパニー解散だよ
た）ホントだね　ま）ねぇ
ま）さみしいね～ちょっと　は）さみしい
は）けどまぁ
は）別れもあれば出会いもある
は）春という事で、
は）3人ともちょっと、ベクトルは違うんですけども
は）それぞれまた、いろんな分野で活躍できるように
は）頑張っていきたいと思います
は）せーのっ！
アデュー！！
エンディング